okay so I want to talk a little bit
today about Republican congressman Dan
Crenshaw he was on the Joe Rogan program
not that long ago and he said a bunch of
stuff that really didn't make sense
about socialism and healthcare and Joe
Rogan pretty effortlessly sort of made
mincemeat of Dan Crenshaw's arguments
and I did a story about it and there was
great interest in it and clearly some of
my audience has been following Dan
Crenshaw since because I got a bunch of
emails this morning about an interview
that Dan Crenshaw gave to Fox & Friends
I believe it was yesterday and I want to
go through some of the things in this
interview because it actually seems dan
Crenshaw is a dangerous guy in a very
particular way he seems not just
uninformed but actually delusional and
he presents his delusional uninformed
ideas in an eloquent and sort of Ben
Shapiro type way where it's like wow he
seems so convinced that this is so
obviously the truth that it clearly must
be even when what he's saying doesn't
really make any sense and as a result
he's become a real conservative hero to
a lot of right-wingers who were just
looking to have red meat thrown at them
and talking points that they can use so
this is it it's scary to see that he's
almost becoming like a pseudo
intellectual figure among some on the
right and I know you'll be scared by
that idea but I wanted to get into a
just a couple of the things he said
yesterday during this Fox and Friends
interview so first of all here he is
railing against Marxism which he says
there's been a concerted effort to bring
to the United States for decades take a
listen to this always part of the plan
it has been for decades actually and and
it started well back into until window
and Marxism made its way into the United
States in the 60s and they're always
looking to to take advantage of some
kind of situation to make people think
that their country is evil so that they
can justify their own Marxist revolution
that is what's happening here and you
can't be blind to that the plan for
decades for Marxism to come to the
United States
in order to make people believe the
United States is evil in order to cause
a Marxist revolution so what he's taking
here is like maybe a 1% accurate idea
that in Marxism there is this idea that
when capitalism fails there will be a
revolution which will usher in a marxist
state that that that's a Marxist idea
that's true but you've really got to
break down what he's saying piece by
piece because it's a Gish gallop it's
just gift gallop is a debate term where
you just throw out a bunch of stuff and
particularly on Fox News Brian Kilmeade
is not going to be the guy to go through
step-by-step so first he says there's
been a plan for decades whose plan a
plan by whom where was it crafted
because the Marxists themselves are
almost completely non-existent like
there's not even that many socialists
most socialists are not actually
Marxists either Marxism has been around
as a theory since the 1800s so who
exactly has been working on this plan
for decades to bring this 1800s idea to
the United States for decades and if
they've been doing it for decades
they've clearly failed miserably because
there are still almost no Marxists at
all in the United States and certainly
no Marxists in positions of power so so
that part is not true then he sort of
starts taking advantage of this idea of
the left wants to make the u.s. look bad
or portray the US as evil and this is
maybe easier to do right now because the
left is in the opposition when you have
Donald Trump this wild authoritarian
surrounded by right-wing nuts in power
we are rightly pointing out that a lot
is going wrong in the country but that
doesn't mean we're Marxists or
socialists I'm certainly neither and
he's taking advantage of the situation
that has left the
left that has placed the left in a
position of having to say the u.s. is a
bad actor in some cases the US is a bad
actor on coronavirus because of the
failed response from Trump and mostly
Republican governors that doesn't mean
the country is in and of itself bad
that's a very simplistic and childish
sort of way to categorize countries it's
cartoonish thinking the real view is the
United States as a country given how
rich we are could be a force for so much
more good than it is and that's what we
want to get back to and it doesn't mean
a socialist takeover or a Marxist
uprising
so again gish gallop from Dan Crenshaw
here's another clip where Crenshaw
blames the police brutality the
anti-police brutality protesters for the
spike in cases in Texas rather than
Texas reopening too early let's take a
look at that but we're gonna get through
this it's a virus without a vaccine and
we always knew this kind of thing would
happen especially when we had tens of
thousands of people in the streets just
a couple weeks ago okay this shouldn't
have just sort of surprised no one over
300 cities 300 plus cities had some type
of rioting looting protests happening
how do people not link those two in fact
I've seen reports saying no proof that
the riots in the streets in the protests
led to the rise of coronavirus you'd
have to suspend logic to think that yeah
don't believe your lying eyes everybody
wants to say it was a few people hanging
out of bars that caused this that's not
true listen Texas has been reopening
since May first okay we've been getting
back to normalcy since May first and
everything was declining as a result
cases were declining this spikes
happened after tens of thousands of
people got together in close proximity
I again there's nothing wrong with
saying that that's that's just the truth
and we're just dealing with it now it's
not about blaming anybody it's just
about being honest with with causes and
effects so notice that Brian Kilmeade
says you know we had rioting and looting
and protesting like what we mostly had
was actually protesting this is a
linguistic tool that's used you first
mentioned the rioting and the looting
and then you mentioned the protesting
always frame things as mostly violent
when you're against the mess
but the real meat here is the cases
which Dan Crenshaw says is him being
honest listen we got to be honest it's
the anti-police brutality protests that
spiked cases now I set up front the
virus knows no political ideology the
virus doesn't care whether you're
protesting against lockdowns or you're
protesting against police brutality both
can spike cases the facts happen to be
that the anti lockdown protests were
mostly people not wearing masks whereas
the anti-police brutality protests were
mostly people wearing masks not
everybody you saw a few masks at the
anti lockdown protests and you saw a few
people without masks at the anti-police
brutality protests but by and large
people were wearing masks and the masks
work even sean hannity set it on his
program last night so in New York City
and in Boston we had huge protests and
we didn't have a spike and in fact we
see a continued decline in New York and
Massachusetts in other places you had
protests and there has been a spike and
the spike appears to be mostly because
of people without masks and restaurants
we're hearing about outbreaks at nail
salons and the like and even Texas his
own governor said we probably opened
bars too early which is certainly an
admission that things have not gone
exactly right so I have my ideology as
truth and my ideology is health I was
worried there would be a major spike
because of the protests
fortunately the protesters widely wore
masks and it doesn't seem as though
those protests caused a big spike
conversely we're starting to see some
elements surrounding Tulsa Oklahoma that
are seeing more rapidly increasing cases
that could be because of Trump's rally
at which 6,200 people crowded together
well crowded there was there was some
room because it was so empty but many of
them were crowded together without
wearing masks let's just tell the truth
and don't fall for Dan Crenshaw's BS